Fast API makes it quicker and
easier to develop API's with Python.
Tommy will show you how it works in this course,
his first API Crash Course. First API is a modern,
fast and iperformance web framework for
building API's with Python. In this video,
I will show you how you need to get started
working with fast API. First API also has a very
good and easy to follow documentation, which I can
also recommend. And it is also a great framework
for building web applications with Python. During
this tutorial, there are some tips on keynotes
that you might want to take down. But I already
did this for you. So I made a fast API cheat sheet
in which you can download for free using the
link in the description below. And if you'd
like more tutorials, ideas, don't forget to
check out my channel as Cody told me, where
I teach more on Python, and web development in
general. The only requirement for this tutorial
is that you have the basic knowledge of Python,
and you have Python installed on your computer
with a minimum version of 3.6 or higher. Have you
noticed said let's dive straight into this video.
So the first thing we're going to be talking
about is how we're going to install fast API.
Now to install fast API on your computer, your
laptop is very easy. Because first API is a Python
framework, we're gonna use the Python package
manager, which is Pip. So you can just open
your command prompt if you're on a Windows,
whether you're on a Mac, open your terminal,
and we can just type Python, I think m pip install
bust API. Now it's very easy to just do command
line you need to install fast API. You can also
do Dinamo, we like peeping so fast CPI. Or if
you're on a Mac, you can do PIP three install for
CPI, just the normal installation command lines.
So I just like using Python, by free, just
personally, but you can install it anyways. So
I that is running. And as you can see
it says requirement already satisfied.
Now if you walk with Python, you know that this
means that I already have this particular library
installed on my computer. So because I have it
installed, it's not going to go ahead and install
that again. Let me just type CLS to clear that
up. So what that did was it install fast API. So
if you do a fast API, you stored it, you go ahead
and download some files or not just only fast API,
some other stuff that you're going to use later,
like typing or some other libraries, it's going to
install that alone. And there's one more thing
we need to install to let's say, Pip, install
you you'll recall. Now the reason why we say p
p. So you recall this recall is what we're going
to use to run our web server. Now, if you work
with other libraries, like for example, Django,
you know that Django, you don't need to install
any external team to run it or your web server.
Once you just type a command line, if you have
Django installed is going to run into a web
server. But fast API is totally different. Because
working with fast API is a very light library. So
you need like an external library just to run
that file on the web server. So this UV con is
going to allow us to run our first API project
or file on the web server. Once I press enter,
now, I should also be expecting a requirement
already satisfied, because I have this particular
library installed. As you can see, it tells me
requirement already satisfied, the ledgers closed
our proposal. The next thing I want to do now,
the first thing before I started this, I already
gave it to my folder by came to this directory,
and then I created a Python file name my api.py.
And in my Visual Studio code, I already open
up the file. Yeah, my api.py. So this is the
file we're going to create in our API's
are running everything we're gonna do.
What I just want to do is to copy this particular
directory for me to my command prompt and CD into
that. If I press dir, right now, you can see
that I have the file, just to make sure that
we're in that particular directory. And
now that I know I'm in that directory,
let's just go ahead and create our first API.
Now the reason I just opt into this directory
is just simply because when I want to run these
on our locals on our web server later, I need
to make sure I am in that particular directory.
So I can run the file in that directory. So Oh,
this is going to make sense later. But let's
just go into Visual Studio. Now, first of all,
let's just import past API. So
we can just do import past API.
And if we save this and come into our
command line and run that Python, my API spy,
so if that runs without any error, or anything
like that, so as you can see it doesn't give
us any early response does just because there
is that's the teller, the first step has been
installed successfully. So let's just close that.
Now let's just go ahead and create our first API.
Now, well, we need to do to create our first
API, we'll say from first API, import past API.
Exactly. So this is just import first API, like
an object to work when you use this object,
or an instance of this object to create our API's
later. So now that we have this is imported,
we're gonna set up is equals to fast API. We're
taking it from this first API, which we imported
to our creating like an instance of the first
API object, so we can assess this later. Now this
object, it has plenty attributes like the get,
let me do let me go into that now by just some
other things that we're going to use to create our
API later. So now that we have that created, what
we want to do is to create an endpoint. Now let me
explain what an endpoint is, to an endpoint is one
end of a communication channel. So that's why so
complicated. But what that just means for an API,
an endpoint in a URL, so let's say we
have a URL like on our local hosts, slash,
delete user. list if a user so for this particular
URL, the endpoint is this delete user. So this
is like the path in a normal URL, we call it the
path. Let's say we have something like amazon.com.
And then we have something that Yeah, just
delete user or something like create user.
So this is we can say this is our endpoint in
a normal URL. This is the path, we're dealing
with API. This is like our endpoint to just have
that at the back of your mind on each endpoint,
where you're specifying your URLs do
my like, perform different operations.
So my just get a particular information,
a particular data store might be too late,
for example, this great user, the endpoint is
self explanatory is creating a new user. So
that means he will have to post some data to that
endpoint, so we can create a new user. So again,
you're gonna understand this when we get straight
into it. And there are different type of endpoint
methods, body cones, there, there are lots
there are not too much, but they are a lot,
but the core ones get not this get, we have posts,
we have routes. And then we have delete, let me
just explain this quickly. So the get is used to
just get an information or return on information
just to get or return a data or something like
that. And then of course, this is just to create
something new, and put it like that with something
new, or create like a new object in the database.
And therefore put this port is used to update
a data or to update something in a particular
object. So all these again, you are going to
understand when we are putting all these in all
this practically, for updating on Delete is self
explanatory, is just used to delete something.
So as I said, these gets used just to get or
return data or information post is to create
something new or just to add something new input
is used to update something that already exists
in that particular database, and delete it
just to delete like a data from a database
or something like that. So now that we have all
these known, I already understand all these,
let's just go straight into creating the route
HIV, the real API. Now for me to create a new API,
I'm going to do at the Add sign up dot get. And
as you can see, for this API, I'm using Git,
and according to the explanation I did like
a few minutes ago, it shows that I want to
return on information or we just want
to show an information. So if I want to,
like do something else, like posts, put delete,
we're also gonna do all that later in this video.
But let's start with get laughter You say app dot
get a note that this app is getting from the first
API instance, which is what we imported, say app
dot get. And then we're opening a bracket to the
current output slash. So this is our endpoint, our
API to the home or right slash, it means our own
and our own can be like, what what we show when
we just come to our own page, like google.com
does the homepage. So whatever our domain is,
does Just our own page is something like slash,
Bessie like delete. So that is another like
URL, it can be google.com slash delete. But now
this is just the homepage just to make sure
you get that correctly. But now that we have
that we're gonna have a new function, let's name
this index, our own or anything wants to name it.
And the no Ledger's return particular
data, series name, ciphers data.
So what this is doing now, as we say we are taking
from the app, which is also taken from the past
API object hours in a get method. And the endpoint
you specified is the home page or the home URL.
And then under that, we're just going to have a
new function, we can name this anything we want,
what we just do is to return this particular data.
Now, this is just a dummy data that we just input.
But later on, I'm going to show you how
you're going to use it as a Python dictionary.
And yeah, normally when we're returning
data to be written in Python, your response.
This API first API uses JSON, but later on, so I'm
going to show you how to use a Python dictionary
and automatically converted to JSON data. But
for now, this is just a normal JSON data is being
returned. Let's save this particular file. And
first run this and really see what we are doing
on our web server. That's when UV call comes in.
But let's go back to our command prompt. First,
to be able to run these, let's just make sure that
we're in the directory of this particular file.
And to make sure we just press dir,
and then we see our file does good.
Now for us to run these we need to press after it
is the first one we need to add is the name of the
file, which is my api.py. The second one is the
name of the variable you use, most of the time,
it's always up. And then there's basically two
things but ledger says we know that Ledger's roll
this on the web server, what I'm going
to do now I'm going to say yuvika
gonna leave a space. And I'm gonna say my API,
which is the name of the file, but now we don't
write about api.py, we just write only the name
of the file, not with the file extension. And then
we'll put a colon, I'll say up. And this is coming
from right here, which is the variable we give
to the object instance of fast API. And then
we just put through iPhones, save reload.
This is the basic command line just to run our
fast API project for our server. Once we eat,
enter, that you can see it says you've gone
running a PC application startup complete.
And it gives us this particular URL. That is
the URL that says where we should go to to see
our project. I'll just come into my browser
here, paste our URL, hit Enter. And boom,
you can see that I have named first data,
which is exactly what we returned right here
as a response new first data. So this is how
you can basically just have a very simple API.
Now, pass API as is very cool thing that I like
most of everybody that works with fastpay. Like,
we just got the documentation
to automatically generate these
good looking UI documentation for your API.
If we go to slash Doc's. And we hit enter,
CCS fast API swagger UI. This is just like a
basic documentation for all the API's you have
on these your like website, or like your API
application, whatever you want to call it.
But as you can see, it says default, we have from
the endpoint of UI, just slash. And the function
is index, which is right here, function,
give it to the index. And as you can see,
using a get method, that's what it shows you it is
it gets metal, they just basically generate these,
like API for, like this documentation for our API.
And we can test our API directly from this place.
But we don't need to use postman or any external
service to test API, you can just come here,
click on try it out. I will say it execute. And
I come down here, he just give me the response,
which is named first data of whatever is being
done here. Now, we're also gonna go complex,
more in the video and show you how to like
manipulate all this data very well. But for now,
this is just the response that is being given back
to this page. And of course, if we go to the Oh,
students same response, so To this point
we've talked about, first of all, we created
our first API, we made sure we installed all our
past API, you recall on everything we needed.
I explained, endpoint, what endpoints are
and get post, put, delete, implemented.
And yet again, we created our first API, and also
showed you how to use documentation of fast API.
So that's basically all about
reaching our run our first API.
Now, let's talk about our endpoint parameter.
Name parameter is basically used to return a data
relating to an input in the part or in the
endpoint, basically. So we can do that using
either a part or a query. So we have two
input parameters, which are path parameter
and a query parameter. I'm going to show you I
illustrate these right now. But first of all,
let's have low year as a new dictionary, our name
is students. It just filled out correctly, the day
dense. And there's a key with an ID of one, unless
you have that as another dictionary, lesson name.
Give you like john. These are the
age this C 17. There's a class
yet. So this is just a basic, make that small
caps. This is just a basic Python dictionary,
we just have one field India, this is a key, and
this is the value. So what we want to do now is
that we want to return the data of this particular
student using the student's ID. So in the
field, by key, let's say slash, we
can have a parameter like slash,
it's then slash one. So while you
have one It means is you return
the data with the student the as the ideal
for. So before I get into these, let me
explain what I mean by a pass parameter.
More. So let me just come down here.
Let's say I have a website like google.com,
slash, and they have get student
then this is just the basic URL to get a student.
And it can just basically show me all the data we
have in this dictionary. But let's see how to get
only a specific study like this to date, which has
the ID of one, and I can add another endpoint. But
now this endpoint will be dynamic is going to be
like a parameter that the user inputs, that will
be something like slash, then can be one, then
when we go to this URL is the user that has the
idea of Wanda is going to be returned to his to
his user as the idea of two. So let's cancel this
and just go straight into it. So we have this
object right here. And then what want to do right
here in app dot get place first of all, have a new
endpoint, app dot get also why isn't using I
get, and this time around, let's say get student.
Now we have this endpoint name gets
to them. And we'll put slash again,
I now want to take a parameter dummies
want to take an ID of what a user should
input. The first To do this, we'll use the
curly braces, and they will say student
underscore ID. This is just telling us the
previous ID huge basically be collected. And now
they Jeff, this creates in the normal function
of Cassie gay student. Now, remember right here,
it was just blank in euros not in India,
but now we're collecting students ID
underscore ID. And this should be equivalent
to whatever you put right in here.
That does what he just being collected. And
we have to specify the data type of this,
which is our integer so the ID should be our
integer now, or we can just do is to return
students. We're returning students,
which is from year is in the student ID.
So let me explain this. One more Time, what this
is doing now is that we have these adult guests
slash guest today, slash why now why isn't it
curly braces, that's fine like a variable mpg like
variable a dynamic variable. So whatever these
are input here is what is going to be used to get
the student. So d f, get student
there now, initializing the student ID
thing we're giving is like a data type of int,
that means it must not be a string or a boolean
value, it has to be an integer. And then we
just say return students who are turning the
student with the students ID. But what I mean by
this, you know, in a normal Python dictionary,
if we just want to return these students,
because it has a key of one because the students
want. And this is basically just going to return
the value of this one. But since one is to be
dynamic, I want you to do what the user inputs, we
change this one to the students ID damage whatever
the user inputs, the key of that is what should
be, and not, let's say user input like five,
and we know of that here, just gonna give you
like the channel found or something like that. So
let's save this. First of all, let's just
go test it out. If we come back here,
and let's refresh this page. Now you can
see that we have a large guest student.
And instead he knows the names are Roscoe ID
that we call me utilizes students ID is required.
That means we can just test this out, I say
execute the we try to try this and execute
T, it says that we need to input something
here. Now we put one, I say execute.
We see now that gives us a response of named john
17. On year two, that is basically this one right
here. So if we come here now, and then we
try to put something that is not the like
three, I'll say execute. You see the ISIS internal
survey Rodas because there is no detail like the,
of course, let's just go to the URL direct
directory directly, we say get student
finish student then slash one. You see now that
we have john age, we just have basically dat data
proceed to internal server error. Let's go back
to the docs, the does what's the path parameter
is basically all about what we can make it more
we can add more details to it. Or we can say let's
say we can make it compulsory. So let me come back
here. Let's say we want to add more details to
this student id like, you know, when we are
serving this API to a user, the user manual really
good like you really name this today's idea, we
just say student ism, I know understand what this
is like, do we need to pass the student name, or
the student's age or the class or the ID. So if
we don't have a surface financial name, we can
use like, something we need to import. And then
that is going to allow us to have a description of
it that the user can know what to input. But first
of all, let's come up here and input path. To
say that we don't need to have an dialogue,
we can just press comma inputs path, because
it's from past API inputs in it. So now that
we have parts imported, we can just say student
ID, below int equals two, then we can say path.
First of all, we'll say none. Now this non is
so there, if the student, if the person doesn't
input anything is just going to leave it blank
or is not going to once Iran is just gonna like
bring out an empty data. So just to like catch
the error. Remember, when we did it back year,
when we tried to get without inputting
something, he just told us that we need
to input something. That's just what this
is doing. And now we can add a description.
Now in this description, we can do something like
we want the ID of the student. You want to view
like that. So now this is just the description
we are giving it. And once we have this,
if we save it on then recall to our code right
here. And let's just try to refresh the page to
refresh dogs. And then we say get student.
No, because he writes in distribution. He says
the idea of this today you want to say just more,
giving us more description or more details of
what we really want to collect. What you also
more attributes is not just only does it come back
to our code, we have more attributes in this path,
we have attributes like less than two, let me just
quickly come down here again and experience it.
But we have let greater than gt GT, this just
means greater than, is self explanatory, we have
less than, we have D, which is greater
than or equals to also have LD,
which is less than or equal to. So this is just
telling us since we are collecting an integer,
we can specify whether the integer want to collect
must not be greater than 50, or must not be less
than one or zero or something like that. Let's say
we don't want our integer to be greater than zero.
But we want it to be greater than zero, so it
must be greater than zero. Let's save now, we come
back here, it refresh. Now, let's try it out right
here. Let's say we try to use zero and say execute
the gives us this error say, ensure the value is
greater than zero. But that's because we specified
in yellow, we don't want it to be less than zero,
it must be greater than zero. And we can also add
to, let's say we want you to be greater than
zero, but less than, less than, like three.
That means the number should be from one to
two. So if we go against any of these rules,
for me again, in the refresh button, and
right here, we tried out the let's say we
do three presses acute trauma give us an error,
we say ensure the value is less than three,
when I we do two is gonna give us internal server
error does because that data is not found there is
no data with the key of two with do one, you know,
we have that data right here. Right here, we just
go here, the key of one to come back here. Now
you see that gives us a data that does our we can
just add more values. Or we can Yeah, we can add
more values and details to this particular API.
Now let's talk about query parameters. The
query is used to pass a value into a URL
that is quite similar to the path parameter. Let
me quickly explain that again. Now in a URL, like
I say, google.com, slash, and we have results. Now
when we have these question mark, and then we have
variable name equals to something like Python.
Now in this URL, the query parameter is this
search equals to Python. So this is just basically
giving us an like a key and a value. So this is
the name of the variable as we pass undefined is
very, very, very similar to the path parameter,
right here. And the path parameter, you know, we
have a name of student ID, or we have a value of
whatever the user inputs, that's just our
which is zero. So we can have like a URL,
and then instead of having slash or something to,
you know, be on that same endpoint, for right now,
is gonna just have a query attached to that
end point. to having this said, let's just go
straight into using these practically, what
I want to do now is I want to create a new
person a new endpoint, I'll say app dot
get also. And then let's say slash get,
I think by the want to get the student data
by the name, this right here, we're getting by
the students ID for the difference between the
query parameter and the path parameter is that
in the patch parameter, we need to add whatever
the parameter wants to collect in the URL in the
endpoint right here. When it query parameter,
we don't need to do that. Or we just need to
do so coming to our function. This fire function,
I say get student. And then we'll just say, name
is a string. So right here is very similar.
You see it in the path with the student ID is
equals to an integer. But we already defined our
students ID in the URL. But here we didn't define
any team but we are now coming into the function
and defining it. So once you see something like
is it ready, takes it as a query parameter. And
then once we have that I'm just going to these our
particular function. And now, once a user
comes to this URL and do something like this,
I'll say name equals to like john, we want to
get the data there as the name of john, to this
as duties now, and I use a for loop
and say for a student, ID, student.
If students were brackets, student ID, name.
posts are the name which was passed.
And what we just want to do is return
to dance. That particular students
ID, none of this is just return. Data.
Thought. What this is doing is, first of
all, is looping through the values we have
in this student wise in the key of students
ID. In this student, we say if the students
have this student ID, the name of it is
because with name which has been passed,
let me explain his will to we are looping through
this student's ID using while looping through this
students dictionary using the students ID. And
this Jeanette ID is this. So we can name this
anything right here, we can just say ID anything
we don't want to name. But if I say ID pattern
automatically see that as a keyword. So I'm just
going to put a student's ID so it's original.
So now we are looping through it using these,
I will say if the student with this student ID,
the name of it is equals to
the name which is being passed,
they want to return that particular student. If
not, you just say data not found. Now to make
a query parameter, let's just go and test
it out. Let's come back here. Now issue.
Good. So now we have guests by name, or we see
yet we are name required. We can just you know,
we say john, once we execute that should work. So
as you can see now is named john, because it gets
that is really a value by data with the new module
where we try something like let's say, a team.
We execute, gonna say data loss, because
we don't have any data rights in year
with the name of team. So that's basically how to
just create a very simple query parameter and fast
API. Now to make these our query parameter option
now, we can do the so is very simple. Let's say
we just want to make it optional. Like we don't
want to require we come here, you see that it
says it is required right here. Let's make this
option now. We can just say name, right here in
this string Kathy equals to not equals to no
is no more required, we can go year. So dogs
always say get by name, Katsina, it doesn't say
da required again. That means we can try that's
gonna give us an error or something. They just
says data not found. But now is no more require.
Now does one way to do it. But the best practice
is to use the default option now method that
past API is for us. For us to use
these, what we just need to do.
First of all, we'll come right here
is very easy, we just say optional.
And then equals known. So this is just going
to make it optional for us. But before we
can use this, we need to make sure we put
that option now, they from typing import
option. That is just to make it the best
practice. Because these are facts epi
recommends that if we need documentation, also
do it the normal way or just the other way,
not the normal way. This is the normal way.
So we can also do it that way to keep things
simple. We just want to you have a clean
code and a more readable code as the main
points to make it more readable. We can also
use this so right No, this is gonna be like,
not required is going to be optional. So now,
let's say we want to add another query parameter
into eloquent to have to query parameters. How do
we do this? I'm going to show you something. Yeah,
let's just have a comma, I will say test
it. So we just have a query parameter
of JSON is an integer. So if I try to run
this, we should get an error. And I'm going
to show you why we have that error right?
Now. Let me call me not here, a browser.
So okay, you can see that it's
not even going if I come here.
Now you see dices syntax
error, non default argument,
follows default argument. So what this is just
saying is, we have, as you can see, right here,
we have named optional. And then we have test,
which is optional. So Python doesn't allow us to
have like, an optional argument before, a required
argument. So fast the back covers is about Python
doesn't just allow us because Python is a language
writing. So we also have to stick with Python.
If we come down year, one thing we can do is to
just switch to places like changes, or bring it
here or something, we can also do that. But the
best way to do this, so we can have a limited
query parameters and have them anywhere we want.
It's very easy, what we can use to say asterik sa,
coma. So once we have these, we can now write
it if we have a default parameter or optional,
or whatever required is going to
work since we have this now. Gonna
be able to take care of anything that comes
after it. Never call me on it, refresh. It
that should work. Well. Let's see, let's have
that a reloading? Yeah, there we come, you know,
she's ready reloading. And that should
work. Now. Let's give it one more trial.
Okay, that's taking a while to reload we
shouldn't. But that's just basically how to
solve that particular error, or when you're having
an optional parameter before a required query
parameter. So I hope you understand that concept.
Now let's talk about combining
path and query parameters together.
Now, sometimes you might want to do this,
well, most of the time, you might not.
Let's say you want to get two different values
from a user, like let's say his ID on his name, or
the class or whatever, you might want to combine
a query parameter alongside with a path parameter.
First to do these, you know, right here, we
already have weary parameter of name and test,
the length of the path parameter, let's
also call it the student ID, the slash K,
students underscore ID. And then
since we are defining initializers,
to net ID in the path, and we
also come here, and then say,
dent underscore ID, and then we give it
int, j comma. So since we have eta on here,
that is a path parameter, which only in the
function that is a query parameter. So that's
just the basic difference you just need to take
note of. So we are between these two places does
that. So now we can just easily test this out?
Actually, we even when we collect the students,
Id one organizer for anything? Yeah, because
everything was doing is basically getting it
by the name. But that's just how you can combine
a query parameter with us come back here. Now.
We hit enter. So if we say get, no, this is
not what we need. We want to get by name.
We say get no, you see that we are name
test. We should also have students ID
to strike out as the key. If we come back here.
Did I okay, we didn't save our file. Let's make
sure we save our file back ducks it and now
we have student ID which is also required.
That just the basic concept of like combining
parameter on a query parameter together.
This part we're going to talk about request
body and the POST method. So the request
What it is, is like the information or
data pass when creating a new object
using the POST method. Now to do this, first
of all, let's import something right here
for the base. So say from by downtick import
base model, just to be more elaborate. The
request body is like the data pass when you
want to create a new object or a new data of
t. So, I'm going to explain this later, like,
you're gonna see what we're talking about, you
don't need to like know the definition or whatever
that is, just to know how to use it in a practical
case. So now that we have this base, Moodle
importer, we're going to create a new class.
And this class, we just want
it to be similar to the student
dictionary, and let's name the class
student going to take from the base Moodle
let's have a name should be a string is
of an age and use that as an integer.
And then they have a class. Now I
would have loved to have a class boy,
Cassie is seen it as a key word. So let's change
out to like year, the year of the student and
that should be string also, they just call
me Mr. of class here. So we can use it,
you know that we have these, what we
can just do want to create a new path
now. But this time around,
we're gonna use a POST method.
First to do this just similar to say arts app dot
post proposed. And now we will say create students
now wants to create a new object of students are
going to take a path parameter, or students ID,
I know what we do, when we take a path parameter,
we have to define that in the function. So create,
underscore, the desk. router, define our student
underscore ID as an integer. And what the next you
want to specify is student. The students know
what it is, is basically the details that the
that the user submits. So in order to create a new
students object, for using this particular class,
to know the details, let's say the details, the
name that the user saw me the age and the year
is what is going to be saved in this student.
So want it to be because to this student
Moodle, you can see that
these with a small letter and
capital letter. So that's what's really
different. So this like key value,
but now that we have that just go straight to say,
if the students ID that was passed. In students,
what we just want to do was
say, return like an error,
say student exists.
So this means that if the student ID in
is already in students, and the student
ID right here, then what we just do is to say
return an error, does history already exist,
damage the concrete, the same student
with a student with the same ID twice.
What he does not the case, Justice students.
Within the student ID equals to student
I tell you that the student is whatever the user
broad or submitted using this post metal, but now
that we have these, we've created a new object of
a student. And then we can just basically return
students of that student ID. This
is just the code we need for this.
So before we test this code, or let me
explain what we did in this code, again,
what we're doing in the score above register, we
are taking a path parameter of an ID. So this is
per parameter alongside with all the details
of the student, and they were using that to
create a new student object. So please just go
ahead and test this code to save the Permian.
ducks. Now you can see that we have posts not
get any more great students, our students ID
is required. And they can see it says request
body also required. That's what I talked about.
Talked about the request body is basically the
details as the name PhD year it needs orders,
let's try it out. One of our students
have to, though, we'll say, just say, Tim,
give Tim age of 12. See
nine. Now, if I execute this,
see now that it just gave me the response of
what I just created. But now we have a student
ID of two, if I call to get by student's ID,
so let's just get the students using the ID,
we should love that now safe. So let's say to say
execute. Now we can see that we have this team,
with dummies, it has been saved right here. But
one thing about this is that it's saving it in
like a memory. So if we refresh this page,
that is gone. But you know, we are working
with real world applications, you want to save
like your database or something like that. So
you can see that we created a new object of that
now. And then we just use the get to get that URL,
if we want to read what already exists like
true, and want to create it again, let's execute,
we say says error students already exist, we can
create with the same ID twice, does what's good
about that? Let's go back to our code. So this is
basically how we can just use the POST method and
the request body to create a new object in your
new object in our data in our database, basically.
Let's talk about the ports method. As I explained
earlier, in this tutorial, the put method is used
to update something that already exists. So
to do these, first of all, let's have a new
endpoint policy up those goods. This time around,
we'll say patch update. affairs today student
and they want to collect the ID of the student.
So we know the student in which we are updating.
Now let's have a function saying date. Student
we also have to defend us
today and ID as an integer.
Now students just similar to what
we did here, we know our collecting.
Vantage goes to this student. Well,
now, I want to explain something. So
right here you can see that it says to that is
because of studio. But when we are posting these
posting a particular data to this URL, I
will say this student is equals to student,
everything has to be essentially all the field in
the composer. So you've become here now. And we
give a name field and we don't give an age field
not going to work if we are using the students
module for the update. So we need to create
a new model, but this time around to make all
of these optional. So the reason for these is so
that because when a user want to update a value,
you only want to update the name and not age
only wants to update the year and not the name of
a new our body we are using this student
class to for the update method. Also.
The scenario as the user as to input all the whole
data now means he has to change audio data every
time he wants to update something which is not
a good practice. Let's just quiet and create.
Plus our name is update. Student
and does also take from the base model.
Same thing name. Now we'll say optional.
Trained person just to make it optional. To do the
same thing for the age. Optional, trained integer
person and then exactly Simply for
the class right here we are using year
optional and this is a string equals no
now we can use this of this students model
as a reference here. So, these notes tonight
again these objects today now with these each
of it is optional see we use I gives only one
value the other values can still remain the same
does very good. And now, what we just want
to do to say if student ID not in student
will say return an error of like these
particular student does not exist or something
the world this is okay let me quickly write that
though that under students does not exist,
what this is doing is first of all it checks
if the student ID is not a student the damage if
the the ID which was being passed to what we're
doing is if we want to update this today we're
going to pass the ID of the student then whatever
we want to update. So, it will first check if
the ID is present in students will not present
it to you the student does not exist today. You
also update does not exist at least you have to
have a student before we can update that data.
We have to check that first. But if it exists,
we can just do something like students
didn't ID equals to student and then
right now we can just return student
This is exactly the same thing we did right here
dance ID exactly what I'm going to show you where
the arrow is in this particular is not an arrow
but where the touch is if we come near now on test
days see the refresh button now you can see is
the put we have the put method and no let's first
of all let's create a new student so straight
out this are creating with to let's say Team
12 nine now we execute this we have a new
objects or new data or the counterpart want
to update this student. So let's try it out. And
what's up JD students with the ID of two witches
team when I want to change the name to Tom not
team we don't need the age or the dummies this
option also we don't want that he doesn't know
what to do. If we execute this now you will see
what will happen. So now it says named Tom age no
yeah no because we didn't specify these he says
no. They were all the way to get your student
by ID and I just want to get this student
into an execute what is going to happen now you
can see he doesn't even show us the age again.
He doesn't show that he's 12 years old. The is
in year nine. So it has been overwritten so it
because we didn't provide this age on year when we
are updating it also via ride rides as no damage
has no value. And this arrow is coming because we
just did students with us today Id is equals to
student needs to know is whatever the user passes.
So since we didn't pass anything, it just updated
our student that already has a value of this it
has nothing which is but the first take care of
these we are going to have to do it in like a
manual way to come up here to say if a student
Let's name is not posting non
numbers if there is something in what the user
past then doesn't want to update on say to
dance. Dance ID does the name will be
updated to the student. This one does name
is exactly the kind of code wants to
use I'm also going to do the same thing
for the age and the class or the year, the
eve student that age is not equals to none.
See, the dance with a student ID, the
particular student does age equals to
the dent. But ah, Now, last time, we're gonna
have to do it for the year, that's here,
now equals to none, I mean, you're giving us an
empty value, then that's the only time when we now
want to update sort of data particular value, but
a particular key, so you don't give us something,
we are not going to update it. When we give
us something, we're going to update it,
then to a year. This is just the code to take
care of that error. So now we save this. Now,
this is very good, because we've
taken care of that particular error.
And now let's just go ahead and come back
into your and then we eat fresh, this.
Great, but what wants to do first of all,
let's create a new dent to him. Both yes or no.
Let's execute. And now we have that, let's
come to our outputs and update that team.
For now we want him to be 15 years old to Let's
leave this name as blank. Well, now the age wanted
to be 15. So you can see that now we didn't pass
the name or the year. But if it executes, only
so let's see where the error is coming from this
expecting proper name equals interval codes. Okay,
so it wants this to be in double cordial because
it's JSON data. Let's do this or execute.
Okay, especially improperly named interval
codes. Okay, this gives us an error
enclosed in double quotes. Let's see. Now
let me tell you where the arrow is from if
you don't have anything after it, like you
do have another value right here something,
just remove this comma, we don't need this
actually, we should not need that because an
integer to make sure you don't have a comma at
the end if there's not enough to read. So now
let's hit execute. And if we come here now you see
there are only 15 was updated and alighted at 15.
But only 15 was updated. Now we have team
a nice to intact. So this is what we want,
we can also do it again. And now we can just
update our name. And we wanted our name.
Now be Tom. The execute procedure, we now have
Tom age of 15. year over year nine, this is
exactly what we want. If we come back, you know
and try to get to didn't try it out. Let's try to
do it, you can see that we have
the named song working perfectly
the age on the year. So this is exactly what we
want to get. This is our main go. I'll also come
down here to get by name. Let's test that out.
So let's try it out. We have to we have the
name of Tom. And as I said this can be anything
because we're not using it. If we execute this now
it gives us an internal server error does
because of course that doesn't. It doesn't.
Now there are so let's see slash to the name of
song on test 32. So the reason why is because
we definitely changed some values right here
are some code right here in where we're start
to get to take care of the liter. But now that's
basically how we can just update some data in our
in our database if we are using a real
data. It's not like a memory or like
I will say a cookie because the cookies in the
browser or is it like a memory once we refresh
or like a session once we refresh that is gone.
But now, this is how we can just simply do this on
I hope you understood why we went about doing
these. So if you read this code will you see
our saying if this, whatever the value is
is not known, that means it is not empty,
then that means there's something
there that doesn't want to update it.
So I hope you understood what exactly what
we did in this bar. And this next part,
we are going to look into the Delete method. The
delete method is self explanatory, just delete
a data object from our database. What we
can just do know is to add a new endpoint,
we can say add up dot delete, and then
slash delete shouldn't blush let's take
the idea of the student want to delete
as a path parameter, and then define
our function. Elite student new student
this guy ID wants you to be an
integer as well we're collecting
and now we'll check if the
student ID is not in student.
So if he's not a student, that means
it doesn't exist and we just return
an error that what you're trying to
delete is not even in our database,
it needs to be in the database for
you to be able to delete it to arrow
judgment does not exist then you have to create
us to know first before you can try to delete
but it does not decay, go ahead
with our code and delete that
that's two different questionnaires ID from the
students and they just return back a message
thing that didn't deleted successfully now
this is a basic way to just be able to delete
data or value from a database first come here
and test this out. Now if we play around with the
pose first of all we have to create a new
object before we can do that. So let's see do
this a for Jerry 20 years let's
see year 13 Now let's execute this
case study exit so as you can see I press that
twice so that's why I say students exists but I
come here to my get without really created it when
I press it the first time when I mistakenly press
it again so let's say to execute we can see we
have Jerry 20 years return. If I come down now to
delete you can see we have this delete function.
Now that we have this delete function is is
right out now by just typing to an eating execute
j student deleted successfully. Now we might
not know if they are related it let's just go
ahead and press check to see if we execute now.
He says internal server error does
because the student doesn't exist
again. So you also come in now and try to execute
again. He says student does no it is I'm a student
I'm trying to delete does not exist. So
this is how we can use the Delete method.
The Fast API geysers gonna be all for this video.
Thank you so much for watching to this point. In
this video we talked about fast API's and all the
basics and fundamentals you need to start working
with fast API. Thank you once again for watching
this video and I'll see you in the next one.